now growth in China's investments and
factory output for orcas has come in
below forecasts it's triggered fears the
world's second largest economy is losing
steam and may cause more Falls of major
investment markets will a speech to the
journalist child eng who's with us live
from hong kong thanks for joining a
search our day so what is behind this
fall well so over the weekend as you
mentioned the official data showed that
china's factory output was weaker than
expected in august and also fixed asset
investment was also weaker than expected
so this morning we're seeing the market
slightly weaker but you know in big
contrast to what happened in august when
we had a huge global sell-off you know
some of the worries about china appear
to be easing when it comes at least to
the volatility in the stock market so
last week in shanghai we saw shares rise
for the first time in weeks and it
seemed as if you know some of the
rhetoric coming out from beijing and
also the government's continued measures
to help prop up the markets seem to be
working a little bit okay so what will
be the implication for the regional
economies and indeed the other global
economy too I mean the region's markets
are picking up as China volatility
subsides today you see the markets off a
bit again because people are actually
focusing more attention on this US
Federal Reserve meeting that's coming up
on Thursday in terms of the economy you
know obviously a slowdown in China has
big ramifications for example Japan
stocks have seen quite a bit of
volatility lately as people are still
worried about the China economy and how
that will pressure China Japanese
exports going into into China so to what
extent is Erika and concern that this is
at the beginning of worse things they're
relating to the economy's um I mean
we'll have to see how the Chinese
economic data holds up in the rest of
the year so far it's showed continued
weakness i'm off to have to see how you
know what the US central bank says about
its interest rate
decision this possibly this month or
later this year and that actually may
give investors some indication as to
what they think is going on with the
global economy you know there was some
expectation that if US Federal Reserve
officials think that the global economy
is weak and that markets are still too
turbulent that they will actually hold
off on raising interest rates this month
so that decision coming this thursday
could you know give investors that
actually a pretty good reading on what's
going on with the global economy ok
charred anus ever get to talk to your no
Williams